rien ne va plus à montfermeil entre la
mairie et l'inspection académique
le maire de cette commune de
seine-saint-denis a déjà exclu de
directrice de maternelle coupable selon
lui d'avoir inscrit dans leur école une
quarantaine de petits immigrés et ce
malgré ces instructions sosracisme
organise ce soir une manifestation
véronique gallium les bosquets en
banlieue parisienne 15 cents logements
une cité construite il ya bientôt 25 ans
aujourd'hui peuplée à 90% par des
familles d'immigrés 500 enfants sont
inscrits dans les deux maternelles du
quartier
contre l'avis des enseignants le maire
s'oppose depuis cinq ans à l'inscription
de nouveaux enfants d'immigrés pour
pierre bernard un seuil de saturation
été atteint au détriment même des
enfants scolarisés
ce que je demande moi aux pouvoirs
publics c'est de répartir l'ensemble de
la population émigrée d'une façon loyale
et juste sur le territoire de la
république et non pas de d'accepter que
les familles les plus lourdes sur le
plan social et sociologique ne soit an
passé et je pèse mes mots sur cette cité
des bosquets qui n'a pas besoin de ça
bien sûr qu'il y a un problème
mais est-ce que la solution passe par le
fait que l'on est vaste du droit à
l'éducation
un certain nombre d'enfants qui sont
d'origine étrangère et parce qu'ils sont
d'origine étrangère que les évasions
département
les deux directrices de maternelle des
bosquets sont du même avis elles ont
donc inscrit cette année contre l'avis
du maire une quarantaine de nouveaux
immigrés les représailles n'ont pas
tardé monsieur le maire ne veut plus
entendre parler ni de ses enseignantes
ni de leur établissement il ne réglera
plus les frais de fonctionnement de ces
écoles